I don't know why I can't retain anything
about like elementary school but for
some reason I remember all the details
about wrong we are bringing our
childhood dreams to life today
we are trying the wrapped our bars
this was the favorite candy of the
Rugrats children it is the candy of my
youth and that I wanted more than
anything else
Holt I am rep time oh I am oh I am
Reptar Rugrats aw it was so good class
and I still watched clips on YouTube and
cry I was obsessed with Reptar I knew
all the episodes with it in it and I
thought he was a real thing goddess
stinky diaper is still the little
brother that I prefer I guess you make
me love you [ __ ] man
oh no it was a sin it was a very sad
moment no what do you I'm okay okay
bring the chocolate yeah [ __ ] it's real
Wow it doesn't really turn your tongue
green it says it does as it turns our
tongue green magic instruction tear open
yep - Chung and step three is roar like
Reptar
she's beautiful Oh mm-hmm
that's really good I was expecting it to
be sweet but that is somehow sweeter
than what candy are it is need a moment
I look at it squish out I was expecting
a little bit more like detailing on the
chocolate and the cartoon the bar was
actually shaped like Reptar frosting
tastes better than I thought I wanted to
you
I don't want frosting much of those
having umbrellas oh oh it's a little
green okay not as green that I want it
to be it's like a real like sewage green
it's like a very Brown huge yeah yours
is mostly a surgery too
I was really hoping the whole of my
tongue would stick out of my face and
then be like the mask yeah like Jim
Carrey green oh if giving their I think
you need to like lick the the toxicity
tastes like chocolate tastes like
chocolate it's good I think I would
rather have this for the novelty of it
like I'd rather have a full one just put
on my shelf to like impress men that
come and sleep over okay here's my Harry
Potter collection
there's my reptile bar look how cool I
am stout is so real like no matter who
you are
we've only met a couple months ago
completely different childhoods
different parts of the world but we love
the rugrat this stuff like this like no
matter what's going on in the world
stuff like this can bring people
together I'm glad we got to have this
something I definitely dreamed about
wanting all the time when I was a kid
and even though eating it now like it's
just candy this is more about the idea
of like dreaming about something as a
kid and then in whatever form that takes
it becomes real feel there's like a
little bit of magic to it
it's a little magical oh I am Reptar
help I ever thought you do this you're a
bad girl oh I am Rafa subscribe cards
come over I hope I am NOT dot they still
have their whole thing